in stating the history of the
the things that I think often gets
talked about is the window of
opportunity that came up during the 60s
for change and some of the things that
is often talked about to go into that
are the relationships built between
people living in poverty and a direct
line to the federal government through
New Deal policies Great Society policies
the so-called war on poverty and I was
wondering based on the conversation that
we just had whether you believe that
this direct line still exists today if
it's still there or narrowing and
closing I don't think that that direct
line still exists the path to its
resurrection and to get that back on
course I think is critical to the
choices that will be made not only in
this election but now we manipulate
governance in the immediate future I
think you know government is as abstract
as we try to make it it's really quite
tangible it's made up of men and women
who come from the communities that we
know and what this what what this
apparatus does this mechanism does that
it's molec t'v process we move groups of
people towards protecting certain
interests which more often than not rely
on self interests if a particular power
within the social norms gravitate
towards one another and ceases that
power then they cease the process so
right now for instance most of the banks
and most of the Wall Street most of the
things that the Court did in since
saying no transparency and give endless
money the causes will make a huge shift
in the way in which there is a true
democratic representation from what we
were here
that will have a continued impact on the
faculty in drawing away all the tools of
support or the humanities all the things
that we thrived on as a nation to ensure
that citizens who are in need would
never be in dire need
then we'd always be there and to be
generous and to be giving everything
that attracted the world at large to
want to become to America is in jeopardy
I think people always saw America's fair
people always saw America as the place
that was campaigning in behalf of
justice on behalf of good and now that
has been seriously blurred and in that
blurring what it has done is taken away
the the humanity from the nation and the
humanity is expressed from a legislative
perspective and how do we take care of
health how do we take care of how our
children are being informed what price
can you put on that there should be no
price on education as a matter of fact
it should be a human right a civil right
a social right and that everybody has
the right to education was never a
concern about how they will pay for it
and the same thing about health
if you surrendered everything else
understand we have the right to free
speech the right to health and the right
to education almost everything else will
take care of itself and these things
always come out of what is dismissed by
others as a kind of social philanthropy
which is not to the best interest of the
nation because it creates beggars it
creates it dampens enthusiasm it dampens
creativity well some of the greatest
experiences Americans ever had was at
the height of its social generosity so
you take a look just from the point of
view of culture so you take a look at
the 1920s of the 30s when the WPA was in
and they gave money to the local
communities to have art classes and
dance classes and and literature and
studied this tremendous reward and
harvest of culture
actors and playwrights and books and
Faulkner and Hemingway and Steinbeck and
and all the great forces that I wrote to
social truths you know inspire the
nation and the best that was in us and
somebody came along one day and says
enough of that we should stop feeding
that crowd we shouldn't now exploit this
harvest and when the capital moved in
and commanded the cultural turf because
they did art is not controlled by
artists it's controlled by those who who
put a price on commodity because we are
a commodity they if you don't get the
sponsor to approve of you to be in a TV
show that he says will be made and
created in the images that he wants then
we're back into a period where we don't
have objectivity we don't have multiple
voices saying things we have no
contradictions and I think when we
stamped out subsidy to the humanity
humanities we stamped out a big part of
the American Heart American soul because
of turning around to pull our neighbor
up has always been the image of who we
are the thing that made slavery work at
least be dismantle and the final
analysis we're not not just the fact
that black Africans seized their moment
and courageously went into overthrowing
slavery but there was a huge amount of
abolitionists and people who had another
humanity that came with enormous
philanthropy and giving and a basket of
goodies to have changed and that change
gave us a hiring society to a higher
order in which to exist but the enemy
never ever sleeps never the minute we
catch a moment and changed the game they
move instantly to find the counter
change
and they eventually win where we are
right now in our own space in this
country those guys on the opposition
side had a 40 year plan
they weren't just looking at the
election for the next three years the
next moment but and the dog catcher
they're busy saying how do we take this
whole thing over and it takes time and
patience and resources and cunning so
that in time we lost the court in time
we lost the Congress in time we lose the
executive chair him and all that it
should represent all that they need is
time to have their while the rest of us
are down here groveling with these
insane little ideas and these little
might mean minuscule things that are not
really about the real game when I did
how can we be in a war that has lasted
longer than any encounter this nation
has ever had in an act of hostility and
nobody pays attention nobody cares
nobody gets the latest statistic out of
out of Afghanistan or what's going and
we don't really care as a matter of fact
that we could just hurry up and get out
of the air most of mine wouldn't care if
that part of the world went to hell in a
basket we have lost all sorts of moral
balance all sorts of analyses that are
important to take human uplifting
existence and I make that claim for us
because that's what we said we were we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
well that's not very abstract is it it's
very specific having a good a fixed
agenda use of just men but in truth
that's what America is about
that's what it pumped into all of us
that's what they made us who we are what
gives us the diversity that sits right
here at this moment on this campus
trying to push ourselves through this
this labyrinth of
of stuff being thrown at us and trying
to find the answers and the first thing
I think we have to find is where is our
humanity not me is your next job that
was your next paycheck that where is
your next occupation as important as
that is there's something far more
fundamental where's your soul what
really is your where's your moral Center
what do you really hold to be
self-evident what is your truth get that
in place everything else work I think